[Music]
next question
hi everyone this comes from mark alex hi
everyone i am from nairobi kenya
in
in that okay in what regard i guess why
did jesus change water to wine from my
research and according to most seven-day
adventist pastors they say it is grape
juice
you see the bible cannot condemn wine as
it does in the book of proverbs if you
look at wine why did jesus turn grip
wallet wine because there was a need for
that wine at the time and everything
christ did he did because the father
told him
and he says that very clearly everything
the father jesus did or said he did and
said because the father told him so the
father told him to perform that miracle
we're introduced to wine in genesis
chapter 9 then in genesis chapter 19 and
in genesis 14 and 9. uh
we have a lot and his daughters
so so wine has a long history in the
bible
jesus the bible is supposed to
whine as an alcoholic beverage because
it is harmful for the body
grape juice we call it wine but it's not
really wine in the common sense of wine
you go to the store you buy some wine
you want to bring you grape juice you
bring your alcoholic beverage
our bodies are tempted to hold ghosts
and alcohol has negative effects there's
some people who say well research shows
a glass of wine has this benefit and
that benefit but no wine at all has even
more benefits so the further glass of
wine we have this or that benefit does
not make it good jesus had to have
changed that water into the wine which
is the fruit of the vine not the
alcoholic beverage that makes people
drunk and lose control of their senses
which was used by lot's daughters and of
course by noah's son and who told him to
do it the father told him to do it
because jesus said he only did and said
what the father told him to do and say
you can read that in john 7 26-28 john
12 48-50 john 14 10 where jesus said i
only sin do what the father tells me to
say unto you
god will not supply something that is
injurious to one's health an alcoholist
amen and i forget the exact devotional
book but ellen white speaks about the um
miracle at cana
notes that the wine that jesus turned
the water into was unfermented
all right so we are
you